we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's
something funny a caller says that
despite my education i still don't know
anything take a listen i have watched
your program about socialism doesn't
work in spite of all of your education
you are an ignorant twitter thank you
bye
listen there is no question that having
an education does not necessarily make
you smart i think trump going to UPenn
is sort of the the number one example of
that so I agree with the framing of this
caller that just having education
doesn't guarantee that you're going to
be an intelligent and well-informed
person but that's not really an argument
against what I actually said in whatever
video about socialism they're referring
to I don't even know what video they're
talking about we've got a great bonus
show for you today I will tell you why I
am NOT in the studio today what's coming
up on the program in the next few weeks
and much much more become a member
become a patron and you'll get instant
access to the bonus show